hello look at the lobby gamespot sweetie
hang out every Tuesday 2 p.m. pacific
right here on gamespot com I'm your host
Daniel Dwyer fresh back from Germany
full of pork knuckle vice beer and God
knows what else and i'm joined by Alex
new house hey Danny journey with us for
another week right yeah that's true
congratulations thank you in turn no
summer did a great job thank you could
[ __ ] it up right now though some icy air
Tay what up how you doing doing alright
sweet shirt oh thanks you always wear a
nice shirt when you're gonna be on the
lobby I have to now you know it's trying
to step up the game hey office here we
gotta get a little bit yeah slightly
more professional look at this cash I
sent my stepped on my game to match you
a little bit right yeah there's the only
piece of clothing I have that's washed
after spending a week in Europe so
that's why I'm wearing that one glad
you're lean and you two are here which
means we're talking about one particular
game come on that game yeah last time
you guys hide you all we had a great
chat about destiny and now we're gonna
have another one the taken king is out
in just a couple of weeks September
right around the corner and not only is
it bringing obviously a bunch more
content for the low low price of forty
dollars but on the day of released is
also going to be a patch coming out for
all destiny players it's gonna change up
a bunch of stuff let's talk about that
first so the first thing we know is that
dinkle bought out and nolan north sin
what do you guys think about that I
think it's I think it's great like I you
know dinklage peter dinklage is a good
actor hmm wasn't great and destiny and
for them to get nolan north someone
who's you know tried and true and video
games like that just seems like a good
move for them they're going back and
completely scrapping it like scrapping
Dinklage from the entire game going back
and replacing every single line that the
ghost says ship with nolan north it's a
little aggressive we run in his yeah
it's a little it's a little aggressive
kind of feel bad for Dinklage but at the
same time it makes sense and i feel like
nolan north will do a better job okay
another big change Elijah's being
completely scrapped in terms of what
something scrapped but in terms of XP
progression past level 20 just like pre
level 20 your XP will be gotten directly
from quests and sort of in line with
most other MMO e-type character level
online games hey what do you think about
that yeah I think it's good i think you
know looking back at you know original
destiny and thinking of just how light
level work it was kind
a little bit confusing at first is like
oh I kind of hit max level but it's not
really max level yes gear takes me to
this higher level so now you're like you
said it's going back to a traditional
kind of style where it's all experience
based and all the armor and weapons you
get will just make you a stronger
guardian so it's like as you progress
through the game it's like okay I got
right to your armor that has 100 or 300
more armor than my last armor more it's
easier to understand and I think the
interesting thing to come out of that
for me is is this kind of going to start
this whole thing with Charles of Osiris
which is their new kind of PvP mode yeah
with what wow did which is like now we
can P we can balance for pvp and PVE
because we can give special stats to PvP
and like here's different gear that's
right specifically for PvP that's what
I'm kind of interested about they
haven't talked about it but I wouldn't
be surprised if there's something like
there's many more the changes I know
like you would have to go back to the
tower as much with bounties and quests
and whatnot is there anything else
they're doing that's kind of jumped out
here or there the two main ones with
that update specifically I mean I think
like the HUD overhaul is incredibly
important as well because it's just like
they're making it so that you can you
can track the progress in your quest in
your bounties on the HUD itself which is
huge like you don't have to you know pop
up the menu during earring play sessions
and stuff not having to go back to the
tower is also really essential but
really the light level the light level
overhaul is probably the biggest change
that they're making to this you two are
big fans destiny I'm gonna throw this
little devils advocate thing out there
it's great like it's like I always you
know my was a big sort of like
touchstone for me with this sort of
stuff whenever a big expansion pack
comes out they always launch a sort of a
big patch around that time as well where
they kind of update a bunch of stuff for
everybody else isn't the fact they're
going back and like rewriting the main
story character in this game and isn't
the fact that they like getting rid of
this pretty like fundamental aspect of
their progression doesn't that sort of
mostly show you that the game they made
last year was just wasn't that good like
they're changing fundamental parts of
the game okay so you're mostly right I
mean a lot of people on the internet
having saying oh we just went through
destiny beta like to Veda and now then
like now we're getting to the point
where it's like real destiny it was a
real expensive beta sure but the thing
is just like a lot of games now just
again we'll talk trends it's like
it's an evolving system right like yeah
maybe the destiny that we got originally
wasn't as good as it's gonna be now
because like a lot of games iterate on
quality of life stuff and that's really
what destiny did right they found a lot
of the quality of life stuff and they
kind of up the game on that and made it
better and the quality of life so like
um for example you know not only did the
light level kind of get easier to
understand but you know they figured out
okay like factions you used to have to
wear a special piece of armor turn it in
to get your rep now it's no you don't
have to wear that you just pledged
yourself to a faction or right or um
there used to be coo ssible marks and
vanguard mark so used to be separate
things that you could earn and you would
get capped each week guess what it's all
lumped into one now like so there's a
lot of these kind of like my new changes
that isn't that big of a deal but like
for a player like me that's been playing
it's like oh I wish I had that in the
beginning so it's like anyone that
starts now they won't understand some of
the trials and tribulations that we want
to and to get back to your story thing
they are trying to deal with that a
little bit part of it is with the
rewriting of Dinklage and we bring in
nolan north but you you will be able to
like scan more objects in the world now
that will give you more like lore behind
it it's they said it's not necessarily
like the grimoire cards that still isn't
in the game which is mind-boggling
because there's so much deep rich lure
in that sense i guess and this sounds
like they're actually worth reading so
it's kind of strange that they exact but
the best or stuff is in the grim already
yeah crazy so they are trying to give
you those at least nuggets we're in the
password you just walk by like oh I
don't know what's going on now it's like
you might be able to scan a dead body
you might be able to scan like a
structure and you'll get like little
snippets from either Nolan North himself
or I think eris morn like it'll tap back
to like the tower like it'll have this
radio interaction of like oh so what the
hell is this kind of thing like now you
can maybe do that we're also tightening
up some of that stuff yeah it's pretty
important at getting onto the taken king
and forty dollars it's their big
expansion obviously we've had a bunch of
them around the price of 20 bucks which
is kind of a price point people still
aren't really sure what they're getting
for at forty dollars is more in line
with the sort of what we expect the most
expansion packs most MMO packs and stuff
like that Alex first of all as a fan of
Destin even playing for a bunch but you
all
so like you've been very critical as
tears and but probably more so critical
of something expansion box what do you
think about the taken King in terms of
its value prospect so I've actually been
surprised by what they've been saying
about it because you know last time I
was on here i talked about how predatory
the pricing of you know destiny is but
yeah but what they seemed like all of
their rhetoric around the taken King has
sounded and a lot of ways very humbled
like they're acknowledging the fact that
the light level system was sort of
broken and they put you know brought
players down the wrong the wrong lines
it they're acknowledging the fact that
some of their weapons have been
unbalanced and there they made a game in
which everyone uses the gala torn yeah
and as they say that that isn't a good
thing they want to encourage people to
experience the entire breadth of it and
so what they're doing with the taken
King they when they talk about it they
make us they make it clear like they are
going back to the story and making the
story camping something that people
actually want to play it's gonna be like
twice as long as we're not in halves of
wolves i hearing yeah they say yeah
we'll see i mean like say they have been
saying that yeah like they are putting a
significant amount of story constant in
there which to be fair you know that
isn't saying much relative the rest of
destiny but they are adding you know far
more cinematics in both dark blue and
house of wolves had one at the intro
right as one of em more between each
mission you know they've got this whole
like take everything they talk about the
endgame after you finish the story they
haven't even discussed the details of
that yet but they keep talking about it
as this huge expansive like pretty new
thing that they're doing after you get
out of the stroy campaign so I from what
they've been talking about i'm actually
really hopeful that this will be worth
forty dollars like both of you played
the game of bunch you obviously love it
a lot and say how important is this
expansion pack to you as a fan of
destiny to keep you hooked in because
obviously like getting certain like
piecemeal quests and an odd crucible map
and some of the in the old expansion
packs like this this needs to be a sort
of a larger amount of content to keep
you engaged this one's gonna be a big
test for me because it's like I still
like destiny I still like playing a lot
but I've dwindled of whatever that is
for me that's right i compared to anyone
else but for me right so as one of the
hardcore players right this one's going
to tell me a lot of am i going to keep
playing or am I going to play a lot less
and am I going to keep congenial lose
friends
after this one if this one doesn't
deliver you know but they are adding a
lot of stuff so now it just comes down
to really let's play it let me see if I
feel like it's worth the forty dollars
but I will say this is gonna be whatever
but like it is a good I think if you
haven't played destiny this is a very
good values never bit of there Eddie
there I got hooked on there's like
honestly though like I wish like in some
in some ways I almost wish like I was
able to get all of that stuff now for
sixty dollars and understand why we have
to kill a peon I didn't understand why
you kill a Theon the first time cuz I
don't read the grimoire cards come out
in the game yeah you know but now you'll
know why so do you expect to play
through the story mission and be left on
a massive cliff hanger likes you guys I
really hope not I really hope this is
going to lead directly into the rest of
the game you're not directly into the
Kings fall rated and what they've
they've also been saying that going back
and reworking all the bounties from the
previous game in the previous expansions
to make those tie and more they're
really trying to make it all tie
together obviously talking about it like
that like they are which sounds really
promising to me all right gentlemen
we've had you want to talk about destiny
a bunch thank you so much again for
coming on last question and we gave
destiny six out of them yeah right
successes and Jay Alex new house give me
your score for destiny after year one
based on your own experiences Eric edit
an we're doing this base on gamespot
right so no halves right no apps your
apps not enough temple a man noni rose
either I think it's I think it's still a
seven I think it yeah that's I always
thought it was a seven I still think it
is but I can also see why people might
think it's a six-point for me seven all
right Alex what you got I go back and
forth I you know when I'm over five so
close when I was deep in like house the
house of wolves I was like this is an
eight or a nine like I was loving it but
now now that I'm back you know now that
I've heard what they're doing and stuff
and I'm sitting around at 7-7 all right
it's got a [ __ ] thing I hear word
around the office of you might be doing
a review after year I guess we'll have
to wait and see if that's the case you
know taste shaking his head I know if
that means no or don't do it ever be
paya taking king of you okay yeah we'll
see we'll see soon enough
you